what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder
and wow what an incredible episode of
loki and i actually think i figured out
what is going on in the loki series i
think i have figured out who the main
villain is and i have a lot of evidence
to support it and that's the first thing
i'm going to be breaking down
also i think this is clearly the best
episode that we've got from
disney plus including anything from one
division and the falcon and the winter
soldier but
let me know what you would rate this
episode out of 10 in the comments down
below
so i'll start off by talking about what
i actually think is happening in the
loki series and who the villain is
and if you are confused about the ending
and the mid credit scene this is the
video for you because i'm going to
explain everything and thank you to
magic spoon for sponsoring this video
more on them in a bit if you're loving
the loki series so far be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
so we'll start off with my theory of who
i believe to be the villain and how the
loki series is set up and then we'll
dive into the indian explained and the
mid
credit scene explained as well now let's
dive into the
ending explained in the mid credit
breakdown
and here's my personal theory on what i
believe is happening
i believe that one of two different
things are going to be happening here
one is what i've been stating from the
very beginning i never believed that
there were time keepers and if there
were indeed
real timekeepers i believe that one or
all of them
were king the conqueror now i don't
believe that there are any time keepers
i believe that it
is nathaniel richards aka kang behind
the tva
for those of you who may not know who
king the conqueror is he is essentially
the master of time travel and he
is confirmed to be entering the mcu
during the film
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania and
he is going to be played by the actor
jonathan magers now before i dive a
little bit deeper for those of you who
are saying
well it can't be him because they
confirmed him for ant-man well they're
obviously not going to reveal that he's
going to be in loki because if he is
indeed the big villain
that would ruin it and loki could very
well set up all of the events that are
going to happen not
only in ant-man and the wasp quantomania
but in the
mcu spider-man no way home doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness you
name it this is just the beginning and
loki will most likely end with the
dismantling of the tva
but perhaps not the killing of the
actual villain especially if it is king
he will go on to be in ant-man 3.
now as i mentioned kang is the master of
time travel his real name is nathaniel
richards and he's a possible descendant
of
reed richards and also believed that he
could be a descendant of victor von doom
as well
now kang is actually from the future
he's actually from the 31st century
in the 31st century he stumbles upon
time travel technology created by victor
von doom
and the first thing he does is travel
back in time to ancient egypt
aboard a sphynx-shaped timeship and
becomes the pharaoh rama tut
now minor spoilers coming up right here
we have seen
a leaked photo and a leaked video really
of
a sphynx this could be a coincidence or
it could perhaps be
kang's vehicle also kang has time
traveled a lot and there are different
versions of kang
or as we would call them in the loki
series variants
it is possible that all of these
variants got together form the council
of the kangs and created the tva
now check this out there is a version of
kang called
immortus and i believe that this could
be the king that we're dealing with now
before kang the conqueror was
a mortis he would go on conquering
different timelines
he did this until he was approached by
the time keepers
yes they are actual beings in the comics
they are actually aliens from the future
and in the future they are the last
living creatures in existence and they
make a deal with
kang for kang to become their agent and
start preserving timelines rather than
conquering them in exchange for this
they grant
kang immortality he accepts the offer
and reinvents himself
calling himself a mortis the lord of the
other dimensional realm
of limbo and if you think about it limbo
could be the realm which all of the
lokies and mobius and all the other
variants that got
pruned could be in right now they're in
a limbo world
outside of the sacred timeline and
outside of these other branches of time
they're essentially in a world in which
the tva exists but a different pocket of
it
now get this in the comics limbo is a
timeless
dimension outside of time like the tva
and guess what is in the dimension
limbo chronopolis the headquarters of
king the conqueror
now what exists outside of time in the
mcu
the quantum realm and what have we
discovered exists within the quantum
realm
we have discovered that there is a
quantum city this was revealed to us
by marvel themselves they told us to
look at a very particular scene in which
the city was discovered
this could be chronopolis because it
exists in the quantum realm and the
quantum realm is outside of time
this could be right now where everything
is taking place the tva could
exist in chronopolis which is inside of
the quantum realm which is outside of
time
i believe that this could be the case
for loki kang the conqueror could be the
actual villain he is the person that
could be responsible for
creating the tva now the timekeepers may
or may not be real in the mcu but it's
almost irrelevant
the main point is that they are
seemingly being controlled by somebody
and it looks like that person is indeed
kang also keep in mind that ravona
rinslayer in the comics
is kang's love they are lovers in the
comics so
why is rentslayer a part of loki a time
travel show
it could definitely be because of her
relation to king
and she has just been revealed to be a
villain she clearly knows
everything she knew that the timekeepers
were fake because think about it if she
didn't she would probably be like mobius
she would be questioning
everything about the tba but she knows
she knows that
all of the workers for the tva were not
created by the timekeepers she knows
that they were variants
she is in the know about everything why
because she knows the person who is
truly in charge not to mention in
episode 2
i believe mobius mentions that there is
another secret analyst
that ravona has on the side that mobius
doesn't know about this could very well
be king
and since she knows everything and is
essentially evil
she is probably in it with kang so i
truly do believe
that kang is the villain of the loki
series because you have to imagine that
there are
very few people out there in the marvel
universe that could create
a sacred timeline that could create the
tva
that could create an organization that
could literally delete
branch timelines there are cosmic
entities out there that could possibly
do this but then there is kang who is
the master of time so kang just makes
sense especially since they already
announced that jonathan majors is
playing kang
in quantum mania now there is another
possible option
we talked about this on my live show
with my co-host culture chris over at
cosmic culture
if you're not subscribed to that channel
be sure to go over and do so but the
other option could be
that it's actually loki another variant
of loki is actually responsible for
creating the tva
if there's one thing that we learned
from juan division and the falcon and
the winter soldier is that these disney
plus shows do
really focus on the main characters in
the title
one division the falcon and the winter
soldier and loki
i would not be surprised if some variant
of loki a
king loki was in charge of everything
especially if you think about
a common theme that each episode has
kind of had so far and that
is a superior loki arloki has wanted to
feel like the superior loki this entire
time
and it's very clear that sylvie believes
her to be the superior loki so it's
pretty clear that this is how
loki and possibly every variant of loki
feels they are the god of mischief
a god above people even above themselves
and if it is some type of king loki
responsible for
creating the tva what bigger threat
could there be to that loki than
all of the other loki's because it seems
very clear that loki's in particular
get on the tva and the so-called time
keepers
nerves in fact they brought both loki's
into the timekeeper's presence just to
kill them
so clearly there is some type of
relevance with loki could it be
perhaps because loki himself a variant
of loki
created everything and kind of hates
himself because in this self-assured
narcissistic way he believes that
only himself could take him down these
are my two theories on who could be
behind everything but i do
think i hit the nail on the head with
the kang theory
to me there is a lot that lines up to
make this all seem
pretty legitimate but you'll have to let
me know what you think about this
but before we continue please allow me
to thank magic spoon for sponsoring this
video
magic spoon has done something that
nobody else has ever managed to do
they have managed to make a healthy
cereal that
actually tastes good now we're all
trying to look good and i personally
love cereal but cereal just
isn't healthy but nobody has managed to
make a good
healthy cereal that doesn't taste like
cardboard until
now magic spoon has zero grams of sugar
15 grams of protein and only four net
grams of carbs in each serving and also
only 140 calories and they actually
taste good and they have tons
of different flavors and you can buy a
variety pack that has cocoa
fruity frosted and peanut butter i don't
know why it took
so long for somebody to make a cereal
that is healthy for you but also
tastes amazing with different flavors
but magic spoon has
finally did it so click the link down
below to grab a variety pack and try it
today and be sure to use promo code
cosmic at checkout to get five dollars
off any order or go to magicspoon.com
cosmic and get this magic spoon is so
confident you'll like the product it's
backed with 100 happiness guarantee so
if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked so in episode three
sylvie revealed to loki that the tva
wasn't actually created by the
timekeepers
she told him that all of the people that
worked there were actually
variants taken from different timelines
from there their memories were erased
and then they were told that they were
created by the timekeepers and they
worked for the tva they were created for
that specific purpose and didn't know
any life outside of that this was
obviously a lie
they were actually variants who had real
lives sylvie told this to loki and then
loki told this to mobius now of course
mobius goes on and realizes the truth
that
loki is telling him the truth and he is
a variant
he realizes that rinslayer who he liked
couldn't be trusted
and for good measure it looks like she
pretty much killed hunter c20
after hunter c20 realized that she did
indeed have a life so at the end of
episode 2
where hunter c 20's mind was kind of
going crazy and she kept saying
it's real it's real what she was
referring to was
her life before the tva her life as an
actual person
it's real her old life was real so
moebius takes rinslayer's temp pat he
exchanges it for his
walks away and finds out the truth he
goes to loki
and says i believe you and we have to
trust each other loki then calls him his
friend and the two of them do indeed
trust each other and go on
to start their plan unfortunately their
plan is cut short as
rinslayer obviously realizes that her
tin pad is not hers but it is
indeed mobius's so she is waiting for
loki and mobius when they come out
now mobius tries to play it cool but he
obviously realizes that
rinslayer knows and it's kind of the end
of the line for him he mentions his old
life before the tva and says maybe i
even had a jet ski which kind of touches
my heart because all i want is for him
to ride a jet ski in this series but
unfortunately right after he says that
rinslayer says prune him and they do now
of course i'm going to touch back on
this in just a bit but let's keep going
and talk about how
loki and silvie end up in front of the
timekeepers
on the way there in the elevator sylvie
asks rinslayer
if she remembers her she took her when
she was a young kid and she took her
before rinslayer was actually a judge
she was a hunter
she says yes i remember you and of
course she does she was the loki that
got away and caused all these problems
and got in a lot of trouble for it but
sylvia wanted to know
what her crime was against the sacred
timeline to make the tva come after her
as a kid and track her down her entire
life chasing her in which
rinslayer replies i don't remember which
is a devastating
blow to sylvie however it definitely
seems like she is lying
and definitely saying this to
intentionally hurt
sylvie so i do believe that we will find
out why the tba went after her when she
was just a kid
at some point in time in the series now
right before they take
sylvie she has a talk with hunter b15
because in the second episode
she enchanted hunter b-15 in which
hunter b-15
remembered some of her past life and she
realizes that she did have a life
before the tva so she confronts sylvia
about this and asks her to show her
her life before the tba in which sylvie
does show her and hunter b15 says
i looked happy so from here on out she
realizes that the tva lied to her she
was actually
taken from a timeline and not created by
the tva and decides to help sylvie and
loki out
we go into the timekeeper's room and we
finally meet the timekeepers
or do we hunter b15 walks in and throws
sylvie her sword then hunter b-15
sylvie and loki all fight together
fighting the other hunters
eventually they win sort of it doesn't
look like they actually kill hunter b-15
if you notice they just punch her and
she falls to the ground so it's almost
like she just gets knocked out and is
down
she definitely wasn't pruned but
eventually loki and sylvie defeat all of
the hunters and rinslayer
and the timekeepers say you're a child
of the tva2 sylvie we can talk
in which sylvie immediately throws her
sword at the timekeeper's head
it falls to the floor and the
timekeepers immediately start
laughing why because they're not
actually real they're androids and they
instantly deactivate after
laughing at sylvian loki and not to brag
but i have called this from the very
beginning
i did say that i don't think the
timekeepers are real and that's because
i believe that the true villain
is king and more on that in just a bit
now from here a very
important part happens both sylvie and
loki thought that the timekeepers were
in charge of the tva but they realized
that it goes higher
and they don't know who created the tva
but loki turns the sylvie and says
i have to tell you something he says we
will figure this out in which sylvie
asks how do you know that and loki says
because uh back on lamentus then he
pauses for a bit and says
this is new for me and then
unfortunately he gets pruned
now real quick to answer the question
what was he going to say to sylvie
i believe it was i love you yes he fell
in love with himself and this is
actually addressed in a pretty clever
way in the mobius scene
mobius lies to loki and tells him that
they killed sylvie
he then just sits there and studies loki
and he says
come on you like her and he starts to
kind of make fun of him asking does she
like you too
then he starts to kind of laugh at the
situation saying two variants of the
same being especially
you forming this kind of sick twisted
romantic relationship
that's pure chaos that could break
reality and that's when he talked about
a
nexus event the nexus event was really
the two loki's falling in love with each
other mobius says what an incredible
seismic narcissist
you fell for yourself which is weird but
also not weird and i'm also oddly
okay with it i mean heck the moral story
of loki could be
love yourself but that is what he was
going to tell
sylvie i love you but he gets pruned and
then sylvie turns it on rinse layer she
tells her to kill her
but sylvie spares her and tells her
you're going to tell me everything
then we have a post-credit scene which
is truly epic and comes as a very big
relief we see loki lying on the ground
panting heavily
he says is this hell am i dead and we
hear a voice say
not yet loki gets up and we hear another
voice say but you will be unless you
come with
us we then see four different variants
of
loki and they are very very different
here richard e grant's character is
finally revealed he is
listed under the cast credits as classic
loki and as we see here
he definitely has a super comic accurate
classic
loki look we then have duobia apare
who is listed as boastful loki and this
loki is a mystery especially if you
consider the fact that he is holding
some type of hammer
could this be a different type of
mjolnir thor's hammer or could this be
loki's very own hammer that he gets
possibly from odin or
could he have made this himself in his
own different timeline
then we have kid loki kid loki comes
right from the comics but kid loki is
holding something very in particular a
crocodile loki
now in the comics there is a thor frog
but we haven't actually seen a crocodile
loki and we haven't seen boastful loki
before
but the big question really is here and
i know everybody has been wondering
where exactly are they and thanks to
some trailers that have already been
shown i believe we have actually figured
this out
it seems very clear now that when people
get pruned
by the tva they don't actually die
rather they get sent to a different
dimension
where all the other pruned characters go
if you recall
in episode 2 owen wilson's character
mobius actually said they've probably
pruned
more loki's than any other type of
variant and if we actually
examine a trailer that has been shown to
us for loki we actually
find a variant that mobius showed before
in episode 2.
we see another african-american loki
variant and he's fighting alongside what
seems to be
president loki and other variations of
loki as well so here we can assume
that these pruned loki's aren't actually
dead they're all
in the same place and it looks like
they're about to start a loki revolution
now this does seem to be the case this
seems to be
real which means mobius is most likely
alive as well
which means that this is most likely
going to lead up to
the big reveal of who exactly is
in charge of the tva who created the tva
now sylvie has rinslayer right now and
rinslayer might tell her everything
that's going on
in which she'll go and tell loki and all
the other loki's
because mobius does not know what's
going on he just found out that the tva
did not create him that he had a life
before the tva so although i do think
mobius and loki
are going to be teaming up i think
sylvia is a big part of the equation
here
but of course the big question is who
exactly is behind all of this who
created the tva
are there actual real time keepers now i
will be doing more breakdowns about
episode 4 including some shot by shot
breakdowns for easter eggs but this
video is about the main
very important parts of loki episode 4.
so be sure to let me know what you think
about my theory in the comments down
below and be sure to subscribe and hit
the notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the future videos
don't forget to give the video a like
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof